bella city ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su e
allora se se mi fai carica cazzo
bellissimo fantasma perché non carichi
dio mio ogni volta [ __ ] ciò che ha
qualcos'altro agazzi perché noi che
possa esasperarli ogni [ __ ] volta che
tento di caricare epic non si carica una
sega come faccia a faccia trovare un
gioco non senso quanto è più gli schemi
rimpiazza il video della domenica ma
edizione siamo arrivati perfetto l tutti
ragazzi minuti mi sono io sono io ci
siamo subito eviti voi ragazzi la musica
siena figata pazzesca solo che giorno
dei club nostrani come cazzo ti permetti
di passarmi attraverso sentite qua ci
sono dei batman a caso allora basta
basta ai ragazzi devo andare al sashall
dei club i nomi io non mi ricordo per
cento giocato anni fa sarebbe il seguito
di torti flash online james bond che
cazzo ti guardi
vedi di fare poco il figo con me che poi
son cazzi tuoi
io io io gliel'ho detto gli avevo detto
io e sentite io devo andare così pagare
qua dentro staff sta fondo il culo mi
deve dare modo di entra sì sì ho fatto
ciò che potevo entrare qua dentro non
poteva entrare ma io entro lo stesso s
to use them sì lo sapevo questo nafta
sicurezza prima di tutto devo presente
lavarmi le mani ragazzi solo che devo
entrare nella avanti 9 che sono sele
lava mi piace questo gioco mi piace
anche anch'io entrò nel lavandino a casa
mia c'è proprio bello bellezza sta di
qua o che ha già me lo ricordo dai verdi
strumento dei membri dovrà tenere
ovviamente ragazzi dare il cui questo
coso questo coso lo devo dare a un tizio
che da tonia mi devo vestire così
perfetto ragazzi sono diventato un
maggiordomo fantastico devo portare
questo schifo ha un'anima a uno
scarafaggio dentro ci sono francesca
fatemi andare avanti perché non è
capitata devo dare sta roba un tizio con
i capelli rossi c'è un'abbondanza di
gente che i capelli ironica non ci hanno
mai coi capelli questi ragazzi ancora
una cosa non me la spiego come cazzo è
possibile che se mi giro fa così e
scienza succedere incredibile dove il
tizio che mi guardi ancora così tipico
un cazzotto sull'occhio non mi stai
simpatico quindi evita di di starmi tra
i [ __ ] giorno 20 zio allora qual qua
dentro c'è uno scarafaggio però io te lo
devo dare lo stesso perché sei una
persona brutta ok
ecco perfetto che piace è ascolta mezza
checa che cazzo dobbiamo fare qui 18
sulla testa finché non cade i mattoni
ragazzi si capisce che è una giornata di
merda quando inizia a volteggiare su
delle persone coi capelli rossi
questo è razzismo e le va bene se faccio
assassin's creed sono sia qualcosa mi
dice di no anzi costare cosa siete ma io
salto si è fatta facendo acrobazie però
non so neanch'io come ma si può arrivare
tipo dall'altra parte non sono morto di
nuovo porca fratello il sangue in hd voi
dovete capire che io le scale non le uso
la uso tutt'altro ferrer e rara
e raro dai radar la madonna che musica
spiega contratti completo andare che è
successo ragazzi che mi stanno spiegando
che cazzo succede ultimamente ho messo
uno scarafaggio dentro il bicchiere
lodato a ed sheeran più o meno ho
guadagnato 3.400 dollari perfetto
ragazzi è un lavoro che mi si addice
quindi lo faccio adesso siamo io ragano
giuro che non mi ricordo un cazzo di
quello che siamo in una banca vai alla
stanza delle fornaci perfetto buongiorno
a voi belli gnocchi è veramente sexy
come ti chiami dio piacere io sono non
ho capito come ti chiami 0 mica che
fantasia senti ma che buongiorno signora
presso il women's che cazzo stai
leggendo dei borg warner un perfetto
d'animo di qualche mi piace come come
prost ora mi schiacciano si ma perchè
devo essere un minchione regala sentite
devo passare qua sotto solo che mi
spiace ok di qua perfetto grazie mille
un martello
ho trovato un martel perfetto è una vita
tra che come fa presso red fri on
cioè io più che disegnare pennies con
questo cosa non so che cosa fare quindi
questo è un pene ti picchio la famiglia
con queste cos'è sì certo non si scalzo
cazzo non sarà il martello della chicco
questa java fan cuoca adesso mi sono
ricordata che serve
ok perfetto rega perché poi non si è
spaccato un cazzo quindi potevo non so
che cosa serve il ghiaccio a niente ma
niente doveva andare dico ecco lo sapevo
fondo gravide fibers perfetto
fotografare gli uccelli che frase
bruttissima da dire c'è nessuno perché
ecco fatti fatico a caso è sto andando
completamente a minchia salve mi sono
intrufolati stimo in sto posto brutto
cos'è
l'aja 22 lucchetti addirittura non 12
giorno sentiva c'è un piccione di ma ha
già messo è maltrattamento di animali
regate corse grosso sto piccione magari
ogni riferimento sessuale di questo vino
metterò l'icona di rocco siffredi in
basso a destra perché ci sta uccello
bello grosso ti vai a fare una foto con
me
bravo mettiti in posa sexy proprio
perfetto grandi
ragazzi è esploso l'uccello che hanno
stipendi così prezioso da essere chiuse
a chiave da due lucchetti vai così
uccelli per tutti oggi perfetto aridi e
questo prima e nell'effetto che faccio
alle donne
fatemi capire un attimo dove stiamo
andando fatemi capire dove sono gli
altri lucia già nostra parte sta parte
un casino ragazzi e devo veramente
saltare la sopra si è fatta ascoltate un
attimo devoti può saltare su sti cosi
brutti quindi anche su quello dei
perfetti grandissimo però morto 300
volte l'ultimo tago fatto sta cosa
adesso non lo si padoan madonna madonna
mi son gassato troppo ragazzi basta ci
sono ragazzi sono siccome non l'ho preso
come cazzo è impossibile che non sono
cadute e assurdo andiamo avanti ragazzi
che mi stupì di qua altri altri uccelli
di qua hanno confermato la terza
stagione del mondo di patty è troppo
bello
mi ricordo perché l'ho amato alla follia
ma basta di nuovo qua sia di qua c'ero
anche prima
sono andati tizi gnocchi di prima quota
a ziano non si fuma est ok
ecco realtà a zia adesso che siamo tipo
soli soletti ti va di uscire con me come
sarebbe a dire no ragazzi sa cosa ibra
ma già mi che mi sono ricordato cosa
succede ecco non ricorda ecco [ __ ]
[ __ ] di me mi sono ricordata di
trance ray quella sigaretta di merda
volta ziano enoteche fai la [ __ ]
perché tanto tp a calci in culo stato ma
sparato con un mitra non puoi non puoi
il quella cazzo di macchina fotografica
ci sono i miei selphy che mi scatola
mattina tutto spettinato quindi non
usare non usare ho perso qualcosa come
450 litri di sangue ma sono in piedi
lurida buttana dove cazzo vai doveva
brutta tra vieni qua stronzo a ridarmi i
miei sensi lei lo ammetto ci sono anche
i servi di mia nonna là dentro ti prego
non pubblicare niente era un pubblicarne
ragazzi se quest'acqua mentis è fisso su
facebook sono morto d'amico la macchina
[ __ ] dump doveva cazzo
ho schivato un 3 come cosa fatta stival
un treno c'è un motivo se i treni non
prendo ragazzi però non dov'è andata
dove è andata lurida ball vieni qui
vieni qui vieni qua bastarda dove io sto
andando a caso basta straniera devi da
d'amico ma per quanto cazzo corre poi e
fuma come un turco quindi
guarda che strano vieni qua dai che ti
ridammi con la macchina che dentro ci
sono le mie foto nudo signori ho detto
per caso foto nudo che alzava un giorno
si sta divertendo è vergogna mi scusi mi
scusi anche a lei sull [ __ ] vieni qua
baffo giorno buona cena a tutti anche
lei che è un figo vieni qua brutta put
me vai dove vai si mette a correre come
lo schifo ma sentite legato un po quella
è la mia ti denuncio ti denuncio due
volte tre volte sto cadendo in
autostrada tra l'altro fanta tra tutti i
possibili che tocca dai noto sarà
chiesta nocca velista gnocca è più è più
york a ditte molto pignocca lite e sono
caduto in auto che questa e baci credo
che taglia traguardo cazzo corre come
una lepre in calore che bella esultanza
che cio non gravi thibon di m cioè se
leggessi dell'arabo da qualche parte
sarebbe più comprensibile di questa roba
soprattutto la tizia che mi ha sparato
tre volte o quattro nemico doppio dovevo
farlo a sotto il ragazzo che è stato
strano e quindi non ci avete capito un
cazzo io ho capito anche di meno 6 per
questo ma non importa perché possono
chiudere i ragazzi spero che video vi
sia piaciuto con che ragazzi se il video
è piaciuto come hai lasciato commento mi
piace anche a pagani facebook e come noi
vi da trattare estinzione persi nei
pressi di sky tv ci vediamo il prossimo
video bello ragazzi